تتحدث والدة ابنة جورج فلويد
البالغة من العمر ست سنوات
علنًا لأول مرة حيث بدأ
مسؤولو الولاية في مينيسوتا
تحقيقًا في الحقوق المدنية
في قسم شرطة
مينيابوليس ، وانضم عمر خيمينيز إلينا على الهواء مباشرة
مع آخر
عمر أليسون بعد أكثر من أسبوع من
جورج  وفاة فلويد ، لا يزال الألم
قاسيًا جدًا بالنسبة لأولئك الذين عرفوه جيدًا ، جلسنا
مع ابنته جيانا البالغة من العمر ست
سنوات والدة تلك الابنة روكسي
واشنطن ستيفن جاكسون ،
وهي صديقة ولاعب الدوري الاميركي للمحترفين السابق وكريس
ستيوارت
محاميهم وأخبروني أنه انتقل
من هيوستن تكساس إلى مينيابوليس
للعثور على عمل لإعالة
الأسرة ، يقولون إنه كان
حاضرًا للغاية لذلك سألت الأم
كيف بدأت
حتى في محاولة شرح ما حدث
لجورج فلويد لابنتهما البالغة من العمر ست
سنوات  وتقول
في البداية إنها لم تستطع
الوقوف بجانب الباب
وقالت أم
ماما شيء يحدث مع
عائلتي وأنا أقول لماذا تقول ذلك
لأن  أسمعهم يقولون
اسم والدي على التلفاز
أرادت أن تعرف كيف مات
والشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو
أنه لا يستطيع التنفس ، علينا أن نحصل على
قناعات ،
وهذا ما نتحدث عنه ، يجب أن نحصل على
قناعات هذه الدموع
من الحقيقة  الألم الذي تعرفه والطريقة الوحيدة
التي سيتوقفون بها هي هذه الإدانات ، إذا كانت
المساءلة فقط ،
فإن الشرطي يؤذي شخصًا ما يتم القبض عليه ،
وليس فقط النار ،
بل يجب أيضًا أن يخشوا الذهاب إلى السجن
بدلاً من أن يكونوا قادرين على
الانتقال إلى مقاطعة أخرى فقط لأن
هذا ما يحدث يتم طردهم  من
أحدهم يذهبون للعمل في آخر
، وقال المدعي العام لولاية مينيسوتا كيث
إليسون الذي يقود هذا
التحقيق إن الأمر لن يمر وقت طويل حتى
يتخذوا إجراءات مناسبة ومدروسة حيث
يقول محامي الأسرة
إنهم يتوقعون رؤية اتهامات ضد هؤلاء
الضباط الآخرين قبل تعيين فلويد
للراحة في
وقت مبكر من الأسبوع المقبل أيضًا ، دعونا نتذكر سبب
رؤيتنا لهذه الاحتجاجات ، فالأمر لا
يتعلق فقط بوفاة فلويد ، بل
يتعلق بمحاولة تغيير الثقافة
والرقابة على النظام.  كل هذا جزء من سبب
قيام قسم حقوق الإنسان في مينيسوتا
بإطلاق تحقيق بشأن الحقوق المدنية
في قسم شرطة مينيابوليس
بالنظر إلى ممارساتهم على
مدار السنوات
العشر الماضية وبالطبع كل هذا يأتي في
الوقت الذي نعد فيه لرؤية  سلسلة من
النصب التذكارية لفلويد تبدأ
غدًا هنا في مينيابوليس خلال
جنازته ليوم الثلاثاء ، وبينما
لم أسمع الكثير من
جانا البالغة من العمر ست سنوات بينما جلسنا
هكذا تصف والدها
الذي يقول والدها الصحيح
ويبدأ غدًا  أول نصب تذكاري
سنراه هنا في مينيابوليس
مرة أخرى قبل جنازة والدها يوم الثلاثاء
كما تقول
من غير العالم